foreign  [Applause]  [Applause]  obviously every new zealander has a  right to protest but there are also  rules around what is able to happen on  parliament's forecourt and of course we  would expect um that people have  behaviors that don't disrupt the ability  of others to go on with their lives as  well  [Applause]  uh  [Applause]  [Music]  know  and the people shattered in pieces to  rebuild our country  come on guys  but i'm still reminded that uh relative  to the people that are at parliament now  on the very day that they're there tens  of thousands of people went out and got  vaccinated it is not reflective of where  the rest of new zealand is at right now  all of us want to actually move on we're  working very hard to put ourselves in  the best possible position to do that  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  now